cyberpunk is dark
it's brutal
hopeless
but it's also a really cool way for us
to think about what our future could
look like
you might think of it as just fiction
but in the last couple of years you've
seen just how fast things can change in
ways that we would have never even been
able to guess let's try to look at
cyberpunk from an architecture and urban
planning point of view to see is it just
fiction or is there a real connection to
our reality are we already dreaming of
Electric Sheep
a portion of this video is sponsored by
nordvpn
cyberpunk is a sub-genre of Science
Fiction but it focuses on the darker
side of Technology often Bleak dystopian
Futures you have a technologically
advanced yet declining Society where
people constantly struggle to maintain a
sense of self in the face of Technology
that's becoming so Superior it's
typically said in a dark urbanized and
globalized world with the gritty
underground subculture with things like
cyborgs virtual reality Ai and
cybernetic implants big corporations
control everything and technology is
both a lifeline and a leash it's what
you need to survive and yet it's the
tool that controls them something nice
[Music]
one of the key features of a cyberpunk
city is the density and complexity we
have towering skyscrapers usually
overpopulated and polluted we have
Labyrinth and streets and Alleyways and
a vast network of interconnected
Technologies
[Music]
basically an urban jungle where people
are forced to navigate a complex and
dangerous landscape to survive but at
the same time cyberpunk cities can be
places of opportunity and possibility
where the marginalized can carve out a
niche for themselves and so I don't
think it's an accident that the most
common recurring cities in cyberpunk are
set in cities like Tokyo L.A Hong Kong
or London North America it's the place
of hope the American dream but it's also
an icon of capitalism and Asia super
dens technologically advanced cities but
there's a lot of uncertainty about the
future but there's another more obvious
reason cyberpunk emerged in the 80s and
90s where the US and Japan were at the
Forefront of technological innovation we
saw the rise of Silicon Valley as well
as the rise of Japan's tech industry so
these areas became associated with
cutting-edge technological development
and so it served as a natural backdrop
for these cyberpunk stories
thank you
[Music]
okay stop
in the original ghost in the shawl
there's only one scene where you can
obviously distinguish kids in the
environment having children in cities is
not just important for social stability
economic growth cultural continuity but
also for urban planning they bring life
and energy to public spaces they bring
spontaneity and play and fun and in fact
public spaces that are designed with
kids at the Forefront it can actually
lead to a more vibrant space for
everyone
just look at this project super cute in
Denmark by BRC angles architect
instead of creating isolated playgrounds
for kids they integrated the play areas
within the larger public realm and by
doing that they made the entire area
more interactive more inclusive more
accessible and more fun for everyone
[Music]
the absence of children in cyberpunk is
a very obvious in the design of these
cities and it just speaks to a society
that's not only struggling with crime or
cost of living but also a society that
has no hope and no vision for the future
and this isn't just fiction places like
Japan and Korea they're already
experiencing a pretty scary birth
Decline and you can actually see how
that's already impacting the economy and
the real estate market the problem is
obviously pretty complex and there's a
lot of factors that go into it like the
kind of social tolerance to completely
shutting yourself off from society
but it could also simply be that the
lifestyles aren't really demanding and
the long working hours just leave very
little time for personal life
that plus the rising cost of living
not really the ideal condition for
starting a family whatever is the Crux
of the problem if this continues to
happen in the next couple of generations
we're probably going to be seeing what
we're seeing in these dystopian
cyberpunk worlds
this is a very iconic scene in both
Blade Runner and Blade Runner 2049 the
corporations are represented by huge
bootless style buildings that are kind
of shaped like my impairments at first
glance it kind of looks like the design
was optimized for planes compared to a
traditional Tower these stepped pyramids
have a very large Landing surface I
think the reference to my impairments
was actually really intentional these
were religious and political structures
they used it for rituals sacrifices for
observing the stars and some even had
tombs of important rulers so these
corporate Towers get an almost religious
connotation which actually makes a lot
of sense because this is the place where
they create the replicants but unlike
these real Mayan pyramids the sheer
scale and density of these structures
suggests that they have zero regard for
life on the street
in City Planning we have density limits
the area of the site times the allowable
density for that zone basically if the
building's taller it needs to be Slimmer
if it's fatter than it needs to be
shorter because the mass of the building
it affects the daylight the wind and it
affects in creating safe and pleasant
spaces for people on the street so these
massive structures they completely
dominate the cityscape and also reflects
the power and control that these
corporations have over Society
later when you look at Decker's
apartment you'll see these tiles these
details are actually from Frank Lloyd
Wright's Ennis house which is an example
of the textile block house or the Mayan
Revival house these interlocking
concrete forms create a geometric
pattern that were inspired by the Mayan
pyramids I don't know if this was
intentional or not but maybe it's
suggesting that these corporations reach
all the way into the depths of people's
private lives and fast forward to Blade
Runner 2049 you'll see a very similar
Motif in the tiles at Kay's apartment so
maybe not a coincidence after all
it really seems that cyberpunk studies
Have Eyes everywhere there's so many
different ways to profile you there's
cameras and ID devices even the
structure of a building is designed to
create this Aura of surveillance in
Blade Runner the LAPD building is also a
building in the brutalist style it's
designed to have a large Landing surface
for the flying vehicles and it's almost
an inverse pyramid with a wider top and
a smaller bottom
this towering gesture suggests
surveillance of overlooking and when
you're on the ground plane it feels
really overwhelming an IHS study
predicted that the number of
surveillance cameras worldwide would
reach 1 billion by 2021 and that was
already two years ago 54 of the world's
CCTV cameras are actually located in can
you guess China according to
540 million that means there's 372
cameras per 1000 people given the
country's population of 1.46 billion
remember Minority Report that's already
kind of happening to China
a man enters a room and tells you a
vocal fry what do you say sells so so
are you an architect or just a YouTuber
interlinked interlinked will you cry
like a baby if this video doesn't
perform well sells cells a muskrat is
drowning because he can't swim anymore
what do you do interlinked enter
what's a muskrat
do you know what a nutria is no aquaca
Capri virus
a beaver do you know what a beaver is
aren't you from Canada wait your data is
scrambled I can't track your location
anymore that's because I'm using nordvpn
to hide my current
nor VPN provides the best and fastest
privacy protection on the planet so I
can stay safe from malware fishing and
man in the middle attacks while my
privacy is protected with Next
Generation encryption if you don't
comply I'm going to geofence all your
favorite content
on traveling or while I'm at home but
you just have to make one mistake and
we'll find a way to track you down if my
personal information is leaked on the
web for any reason the dark web monitor
is going to notify me instantly so good
luck with that uh okay so I'm going to
talk with my manager about this uh you
hold on and wait there okay sure
by the way if you follow the link in my
description you can get four extra
months off any two-year plan that
includes everything that I just
mentioned plus a lot more also if you
don't like it there's a 30 day money
back guarantee
you know what I'm gonna leave now and
get back to the video wait you're so far
away from Baseline interlinked sales
don't don't leave me alone
by the way if you guys are curious about
how we made this video I created a
booklet that contains all of our process
and if you're a spoon or a producer of
this channel it's completely free all
the links are in the description
[Music]
in both of the Blade Runner movies
there's lots of great examples of what
you would call brutalist architecture
brutalism emerged in the 1950s and when
Philip Kate dick wrote do Android stream
of electric sheep in 1961 which is the
book that Blade Runner was based on
brutalism was thought to be futuristic
ahead of its time and actually it was
considered kind of radical especially
compared to the smooth clean sterile
quality of modernism which came before
it it was even considered a socialist
form of architecture these bare
structures the idea was that they
provided a kind of blank canvas that
could be infilled by people's
experiences over time it was the kind of
architecture that instead of saying look
at me it came alive only by involving
people it was Democratic it was social
and it was morally right
or that was the idea just look at this
concrete deteriorates and weathers
really badly over time despite these
Grand Social Visions it turns out people
don't actually like hanging out in these
massive raw concrete spaces
So eventually these buildings became
neglected but the problem is because
these buildings are just so massive and
dense with concrete apparently it will
create a huge amount of carbon footprint
to demolish it so we're stuck with these
cold raw concrete monsters
[Music]
by contrast this is also another very
common scene in cyberpunk
bright neon streets with buildings
covered in advertising in most cities
the city planning restricts and controls
this type of signage except for special
zones for example Times Square
Piccadilly Circus Shibuya Crossing or
Dundas Square
from a purely capitalistic standpoint of
course it makes sense to use the facade
for advertising since most buildings the
facades don't really serve a functional
purpose but not only does it create
visual pollution and light pollution
leading to constant distraction and
fatigue in people and any kind of
wildlife around it not only does it
encourage over consumption not only does
it encourage jontus faces that are
supposed to be public spaces
commercializing building facades lead to
a loss of identity
[Music]
you know what you say to a soccer player
who's hogging the ball and going in
circles
they say he's doing a Venetian
because that's how people move through
Venice through the Labyrinth and alleys
Venice is one of those places where the
city is an integral part of the person's
identity
so in Venice when buildings are being
renovated they cover it up with a tarp
with an exact photo of the facade
because to go months or years without
that building it would be like losing a
limb Walter Benjamin once said that to
dwell is to leave traces buildings are
supposed to reflect the local flavor or
the culture the history and it's
supposed to be a reflection of the
people who live there so when we cover
up the building's facades with ads it
takes away the unique character or the
spirit of that place and we start to
lose identity not just in our cities but
also in ourselves
a Public Square is a space that's owned
and maintained by the government or a
public entity and it's accessible to
everyone public squares are considered
to be a part of the public domain and
they're governed by laws that regulate
the use of public spaces in contrast a
privately owned square is a space that's
owned and maintained by a private
individual or a company or an
organization these spaces are typically
located on private property like a
shopping mall or a corporate campus and
although they might feel public they're
actually only accessible to people who
are permitted to enter the property I
talked about skyways in my last video
about mega cities and how even though
that's how most people get around in the
winters it's not actually a public space
if you linger for too long or you look
like a unsavory character or you're just
a demographic that's not deemed
desirable they're in their full rights
to kick you out so when our public
spaces start to get taken over by
private interests in the end they can
set the rules and it might not seem like
a big deal until it is
for example zuccotti park or Liberty
Plaza Park in New York City is a
privately owned public space and in 2011
it was a site of Occupy Wall Street
where protesters camped out for several
weeks for a peaceful protest but in
November 2011 the protesters were
evicted although it wasn't their full
right to free speech and assembly
because the owner of the space
Brookfield properties allegedly
complained to the city about them being
there yeah
abolish all forms of rent control
abolish all forms of Social and
affordable housing privatized Wall
Street
squares public spaces and Parks whole
urban districts these are not the
government mandates of a cyberpunk movie
this is directly pulled from the eight
point Manifesto proposed by a prominent
partner at zaha Hadid architect one of
the most well-known architecture
practices in the world when I asked
Chachi BT my new best friend on his
thoughts on cyberpunk and its depiction
of corporate dominance it said although
cyberpunk movies can be a source of
inspiration caution or critique they
should not be taken as prescription of
the future I beg to differ commercial
interests are blending so seamlessly in
our lives and as technology gets better
and better every year and as we rely on
them more and more we are giving away
control over our privacy over our
identity even over our own thoughts
while it's impossible to predict the
future I think we're at a critical time
right now how we address these
challenges and the choices that we make
it could really change the trajectory of
our future that's why it's so important
that we stay informed that we advocate
for change that we get involved in our
communities and we also consume
responsibly and that's the only way we
can avoid a dystopian future and pave
the way for a more Equitable and
promising Society because in the end
dystopian dreams they are reflections of
our current fears
foreign
ER sounds much better than two Android's
Dream of Electric Sheep do you agree
cells yes this video getting a little
bit too long sells
I love you guys please don't leave me
alone here I just want to be interlinked
if you are still watching maybe consider
subscribing and like the video
interlinked
Ryan
[Music]